hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer weiteren folge fifa 13 ultimate
team rote glory eigentlich wollte ich
heute gar nicht ultimativen spielen weil
ich eigentlich also heute wenn ich
gerade das hier aufnehmen ist dienstag
und heute ist eigentlich dingens tag
hier wäre es happy hour und irgendwie
meinte kiefer heute machen noch keine
happy hour und ja und ich nehme heute
extra frei von allen sachen und die
lorenzkirche aufnehmen dann machte ich
verspüre keine power
naja jedenfalls habe ich schon ein pack
so gezogen
und komischerweise übrigens letztes mal
ich wollte eigentlich nicht mehr spielen
wenn ich nicht aufnehme letzte mal wurde
mir einfach so ein up recht links geben
obwohl ich das eigentlich gewonnen ob
das letzte spiel und ich hab mal
dazwischen gespielt und deswegen habe
ich jetzt ein abbruch dings bekommen wir
müssen die situation vorne machen weil
das ja eigentlich schlimm dann machen
wir halt noch mal von vorne ist für euch
auch glaube ich besser das habt ihr euch
auch gewünscht und ich würde sagen ich
ziehe jetzt erstmal hier sein komisches
pack ich habe noch ein paar fifa points
ich hoffe mal dass irgendwas gutes drin
mariano kein planen wir das ist sieht
aber ganz gut aus 19 vereinen 980 tempo
lässt sich bestimmt gut fertig beifahrer
caddy nicht kostüm torwart kay nicht
geben meistens nicht so gut weg gegen
verträge können wir mal abspeichern ihr
team training da meinten alle die
gericht die ich richtig gas weg die
ganze locker für 800 da reinstellen
dann kann ein paar leute drauf bieten ok
abschneiden cms den lasse ich mal
vielleicht irgendwann für özil oder so
so den ganzen restlichen direkt
verkaufen verbrauchs objekte habe ich
voller seltsamer mpeg zogen würde ich
sagen spieler und ich hab mir am
wochenende wirklich eine menge fifa
videos reingezogen da seht ihr liga eins
und zwar trick videos also monte jazz
das heißt was ich bearbeitet man ganz
kurz ich habe übrigens robert
lewandowski gezogen ich weiß nicht ob
das schon dabei war als ob ich das
aufgenommen habe jedenfalls habe ich den
gezogen bin ich sehr stolz auf den typen
naldo kann ich meine innenverteidigung
fuchs habe ich übrigens auch gerade
gezogen weiß ich auch nicht ob ich den
er als gut finden sondern eher
schlechtem service immer ganz gut meinen
fernseher ein bisschen moment ich bin
ganz gut weg hinterm mikro so in jeder
form micro sehr sehr professionell warte
ich hab der 280 er tempo es war hat
glaube ich 99er tempo neunziger tempo an
ihr wart ich wollte beiden vergleichen
naja ich das nicht so mach ich das
lewandowskis besser das heißt ich packen
den wanderer skater erst mal rein und
die sache ist der braucht halt noch
dieses komische vereins dingen guckt
euch das mal an wie viele verträge ich
habe alles durch diese und das alles
diese geilen verträgen find ich richtig
hammer das davon richtig viele verträge
das heißt ich kann die ganzen leute
richtig langem einen verein binden aber
ich werde trotzdem nach erzählt man mal
müssen wir gucken mal da kommt es nicht
somit klar egal spielen einfach mal so
alaba lass dich auch mal so drin alles
schnell schnell verteidiger finde ich
sehr gut
gegen gladbach ihr typ kommt bestimmt
aus deutschland ich wollten übrigens
auch mal deutsches trikot machen also
beim münchner bayern münchen fan bei
münchen für wirbel oder zwei in form
spieler her tage wie heute in den sieben
80er chemie wenn der etat vorne drin
wenn der franzosen da hat italiener zwei
spanier dann wieder deutsche verstehe
ich egal so jogi löw da auch sie habe
ich los geht's
also ich wollte ja nicht mit sagen hier
so von wegen ich hasse dortmund das war
nicht so ernst gemeint
jetzt nehmen also diese feindschaft gibt
es halt immer so wissen die schalke fans
ist es normal dass er sagt dortmund
scheiße ist einfach so mein handy
bimmelt hier gerade vor sich herum
vergessen abzustellen alter was das denn
für ein irrsinn verdammter persson
lappen hier
hu alter ich merke doch das ist ziemlich
leicht
halo spiel doch als ich hab immer das
gleiche problem mit der elgato mein gott
was er das denn
na gut ok wasser geben doch ich glaube
ich muss einfach mal der gartower
bisschen runter stellen oder so aber es
ist auf jeden fall ein typ der der
spielten nur auf tempo das sieht man
auch schon der läuft wirklich nur bei
außen hinter eine flanke macht gleich
das 100 prozent ich was sage ich das ist
einfach so klar mensch mensch mensch
mensch mensch mensch ok jetzt zwar
schnell liebe spielt hier sagt das ist
super was ist denn das schöne flanke man
gewisse leute das sollte eine flanke
werden ich bin gerade alles verpacken
rote glory einfach weil ich mit dieser
blöden der garten nicht klarkommen und
jetzt braucht er nicht sagen
das liegt eine garten bis einfach nur
schlecht klappen kann offline ist daran
liegt wohl schöner lupfer kommt aber
nicht zum kopfball
was mich kritisch wir über so ein scheiß
auf länge alter schaffen dies nicht
machbar durchzulassen bitte komm einfach
mal ein ball aufs tor danke fürs
selbstvertrauen
da haben einen großen mit lewandowski da
kommt sogar den ball hatten bei
direktabnahme
aus einer frei schön auch mal schön
herausgespielt aber nicht verhindern wir
haben an den haben ihre haare umgeht
apotheker dahin so klasse klasse ok erst
mal geklärt
schöner pass auf sidney sam der schnell
seine schnell nein warum schieße dann
bitte nicht schnell warum nicht und
jetzt macht er jetzt bei meinem glück
hat er seine zweite chance sofort
direkten konter tor ein
ok nein auf weiterlaufende so wissen
dass er eigentlich nach ich wusste erst
einmal dieser trick mit dem kannst du
jeden fifa spieler außen nehmen
nein nein nein kommen wir hin so so dass
sie nicht noch mal zum kopfball kommen
ich frag mich was ein spieler los ich
glaube es wird mal wieder mit england
spielen also mit einem englischen team
danke alter es sollte ein long short
werden affeley gut gut fürs
selbstvertrauen auf jeden fall sagen wir
jetzt noch mal ein bisschen mehr ein
angriff wollte gerade sagen und jetzt
auf einmal kommen hier gerade an
gewatschelt ja dann macht er einen wenn
nicht dann ist er hier ist
ich hätte ihr wollt das nicht dass ich
mich als aufreger das ist einfach so
dass es behindert das ist einfach dieses
typische fifa spiel du du führst was es
bis der gegner kommst du macht ein
zweites nein ich will auch so machen so
kann ich mich darüber aufregen jetzt
schießt wieder einen eigenen spiel
anders könnte ich noch daran erinnern
jetzt hier genauso wie letztens auch ich
stehe frei vom tor schießt man einen
spieler an
beim abseits obwohl ist ein
hundertprozentiges tor war aber es ist
einfach so man selbst immer bei fifa
benachteiligt na gut so
den haben wir den hammer holen wir
wollen dir schön dass naldo hat norma
was ich bin
doch zum
es kann doch nicht wahr sein
abgefälschter ohne witze abgefälscht
latte pfosten und dann kommt wieder so
einen guten flanke darum von von sydney
sam okay des options mich ausgepowert
lass mich raten 30 eine gute abwehr und
liegen 20 hin dass wir ihn jetzt
generell sich das sozusagen nur höhere
sätze nein kommt jetzt besiegt man
deinen arsch alter stoppt den verkauf
ich gleich direkt wieder den lewandowski
höheren alters sieht das hier eigentlich
für pässe machte hier von ihrem job man
ich sonst noch was sind das dafür
passende was kommt an nur kacke
verrennen sich meine spieler hier schon
selber auch nicht schöner pass und es
regnet den krieg bestimmt nicht mehr
doch den griff kriegt ihn schon jetzt
mache ich doch schon jetzt aber nein
natürlich er wird abgeblockt 8 was ein
wunder dass alle abgeblockt wird von uns
ja nie gedacht
von ihm ein foul gut was soll es gibt
mir ein bisschen gas stellt man jetzt
sehr offensiv
vhs gibt ab
das war so eine schöne flanke knapp
jedoch bringt ja junge du wenn er den
tech 1000 bar mastering man halt fand er
macht er nicht mehr tricksen
er spielt den ball einfach nur und freut
sich dann wenn er glücklicherweise
ankommt und bei mir einfach ist kann
einfach nicht wahr sein
übrigens ihr könnt mir mal die
kommentare schreiben ob ihr wollt dass
ich fluche oder ob ich das eher
unterdrücken sei während der aufnahme
und drücke ich das gerade viel mehr als
dass ich mich immer so richtig aufregen
kann ich glaube ich mache mal so einen
sonnen fifa ich sag mal live kommentare
wenn ich schon so in rage
keine ahnung was genau sagt mir
scheißegal ja ich weiß jetzt noch unten
passen können ich habe sich gesehen tut
mir leid dann wieder der gleiche typ und
immer kommt er damit durch was jetzt
sehr gut ich würde sagen wir retten uns
erstmal in die pause versuchen jetzt ein
bisschen was umzustellen informationen
wir müssen das jetzt irgendwie
hinkriegen dass wir das eigentlich vfl
rhede
na gut ich denke wenn wir uns ein
bisschen anstrengend schaffen wir das
sogar noch aufzuholen zumindest zu einem
unentschieden
aber auf jeden fall musste erstmal es
war ein feriendorf ski weil so läuft hat
gar nicht und er ist der piste mich auch
ein bisschen an packe ich mal holtby
nach packe ich mal wieder aus indem sie
passen aber nicht nach rechts sondern
anstelle von affeley der kader bleiben
so bisschen freestyle umgeändert aber
es ist mir zwei schüsse und pässe kommen
die hälfte von dem anwalt auch nicht so
super den ich entnehmen kann
es ist auf jeden fall schneller man kann
auch schon mal da noch vorne laufen
sowie steht schon auf dem leaf was geht
behauptet doch den ball lulatsch man
junge frau die sich niemals zum ball zu
gehen
walter ich frei ich hasse es einfach bei
regen zu spielen
das ist einfach so behindert venlo
krankenbett freund schlecht du schießt
alles auf das mit der ist auch so ich
bin auf vorschlag einer partie ist kein
foul
quatsch dass unten vl ich bitte euch
und den hält sowie viele können einfach
betten ich könnte ihr können wetten
abschließt dass ich kein tor mehr
schießen werde in diesem spiel
es ist einfach nicht wahr es kann nicht
wahr sein
ich hab da muss man holtby solo her hier
lewis holtby ok wenigstens besser als
der komplette reform dienen die schießen
in dem ich noch mal 10.000 meter weiter
drüber so alaba mit dem kopf die winter
auch noch witzig weil es nicht so toll
angewendet das war klasse gemacht ja
endlich so böse klasse hat sich schon
mal gelohnt dass ich wieder einsätze so
21 schaffen wir das wohl noch aber
klasse gemacht klasse gemacht lasse
super warum verliert schon wieder den
ball alter ich verstehe es einfach nicht
okay aber zum glück ist er im angriff
einfach mal so was von harmlos das kann
ich nicht wahr sein und dann solche
zweikämpfe wissen sondern durch
durchschaubares spiel kann ich sagen da
geht jetzt nach oben so den ball sind
einfach so sachen ich könnte heulen bei
solchen pässen alte ohne witz ich bin ja
schon am heulen aber immer noch mehr
ich hasse das was macht mein team ok
klasse ball kann ich auch warum tricks
machen wenn sie nichts bringen alter
wieder sobald ich wollte die nicht
dorthin spielen will mich viel für
eigentlich geil was sind das für pässe
klasse passt er ankommt der kommt auch
an gott
ok warte warte warte ein alter das ist
doch wohl symbolisieren für das
komplette spiel von manchester united
bzw konnten von united oder einen ball
und ich als komplett frei und ich
schieße dance aus und das lag nicht
daran dass wir jetzt irgendwie falsche
schusstechnik genommen habe sondern ganz
einfach daran dass meine spieler nicht
schießen können und da ist der ausgleich
der hochverdiente ausgleich männer aus
der hochverdiente ausgleich
danke davis direkt noch 1 okay okay okay
es könnte sogar was werden das die noch
1 1 schenkel erhält er dem ecke kommt
wenn schon gewinn wir das jetzt eben
hier so sah sich eigentlich auf die
defensive habe ich eigentlich zwei leute
vorne steht auch wieder nicht ich kann
auch gerade ihnen wie gar nicht
umstellen
bis so von defensive auf offensive oder
so das geht nicht
ich drücke die tasten klasse verteidigt
muss ich sagen lewis holtby war super
mann also kann ich jedem nur empfehlen
auch wenn damit manche sagen werden
lewis holtby ist noch von der inhalt
warum kaufst du denen genau weil er
solche pässe spielen kann mir gesehen
der kann sich halt durchsetzt im
zweikampf seine die leute brauche ich
das ist das klasse gemacht so schuss
nachschuss und ein einwurf schon mal
etwas so wenn wir gleich das 2 3 1
kriegen aber er ist aber bitte bitte
ärgerlich vor allem jetzt noch vom
vergebenen einwurf
was gut rausgespielt oder was gut
rausgespielt und der ball geht natürlich
nicht rein nein natürlich nicht als ob
der rhein geht man hallo ich bin von
crafter kleiner reingeht
so was nennt man kombinationsspiel
er ist von hinten alter und dann die
bälle mehr diese pässe ohne schlaf ohne
flachs ich könnte da vielfach dazu noch
ok aber es spielt auch nicht sehr viel
bessere pässe und jetzt kann ich doch
jetzt wo ich der defensivkette zieht in
die mitte
wieso wusste ich es wieso wusste ich es
dass er ein tor macht drei chancen drei
tore 10 milliarden chancen ja und noch
fünf mal latte und den pfosten und alles
möglich so verdammt da jetzt kriegst
erst mal so richtig ein unentschieden
heraus kommen jetzt aber das unverdiente
was ich hier passiert ist
nur ein bisschen das machen hier
es kann nicht sein was waren das jetzt
abseits abseits richtig fährt nämlich
noch nicht in der hand ja klar schmeiß
dich hin bei so einem scheiß ball
entschuldigung habe ich nicht gesagt hat
muss meist als neues vielleicht mal mit
einer flanke drüber geschossen kommt ja
auch so selten vor kuba 780 minute 3 2
zurück ohne scheiß ich drücke
beide bank
was ist das denn ich kann gerade echt
ausrastende es ist unglaublich was
machen meine spieler da bitte sei
beantwortet mir das sagt mir das mal
bitte was soll das was machen die denn
da für eine scheiße jetzt ist natürlich
vorbei bestimmt älter
mir fehlen ja echt die worte sorry
beispiel das ist jetzt vorbei
ja leute vielleicht direkt mein
controller im urin schmeißen alter jetzt
bist mich einfach so ein verdammter
bullshit weiter gut mit sagen das was
für die vierte folge road to glory
könnten ja mal die kommentare schreiben
ob ich mehr solche sachen sagen wo ich
echt ich bin gerade scheiße drauf wegen
dem spiel ich bin eigentlich gut drauf
aber spielt eine an können einfach in
die kommentare schreiben ob wir das
lieber weniger wollt dass sich so rum
beleidigung alles oder ob ich dazu
meinen extra video machen soll wo ich
das ausschließlich mache oder so weiter
und so fort
lasst eine bewertung da wenn ihr bock
drauf habt ihr denn dann ist mal tschüss